this is a fox news alert russian forces
are making significant inroads into
ukraine tonight fox's pete hegseth is
looking at the maps right now pete will
you're exactly right now this is a map
that if you look a couple of days
past and forward it doesn't change all
that much in the red but that does not
change the calculus of the russians who
are who have to deal with right now even
more sanctions how they will deal with
that is interesting they're calling for
reinforcements from as far as the
as the pacific ocean uh our border
almost with them in alaska and you've
got new reports from abc tonight that
potentially additional weapons are
coming in anti-tank uh anti-aircraft
weapons on behalf of the ukrainians so
dynamics always changing but ultimately
the russians continue to make gains and
they're they're bogged down in kiev but
the but the uh air strikes continue
across the country let me move it
forward if i may to the next map which
is pertinent to some of the things you
broke down tonight which is so important
it's the fog of war but do our best to
break down fact from fiction of what's
actually happening here's what we know
about what's happening in the south so
you've got
specific flash points which are
important
mayor paul
is a city that would connect the land
bridge here they're being bombarded
they're turning off the lights they're
turning up the water they're turning off
the heat they're turning off the
electricity they're turning off the
internet it's a total siege there uh in
karasawan which is this first major city
to be taken will
ultimately the russians have not
attempted to occupy it what they know
they can't do is occupy city centers
they've committed almost 90 percent of
their combat force around the border to
to ukraine so far and they can't occupy
it so they've put an ukrainian flag
there but they are not trying to stay
there they're moving on and ultimately i
love what you talked about as far as the
uh the nuclear facility uh yes there are
nuclear reactors
that would be consequential but the the
bombing that happened was on a sta it
was on a
administrative building which had no
impact on those the impact that will
happen will is whether or not vladimir
putin decides to use this energy as a
weapon against the ukrainian people as
he continues to lay siege uh so he's
moving forward city centers they can't
control them they're trying to move to
kiev ultimately that's really
enlightening pete and as we've talked
about off camera in on fox and friends
we were a little too quick to dismiss
vladimir putin in the opening days of
this war too quick to dismiss russia
i'll see you in a couple hours you got
it on fox
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else